a good shooter Trey Murphy with a great
block and now green just
lets Brandon Ingram know he's in the
building
touches him up those two John a little
bit and hands are flying going to be a
Double T
I believe that Malloy
rung him up right there Draymond Green's
got to be careful he's in that situation
now where every other technical gives
him a game suspension
and this these games every one of them
is going to be crucial you don't want to
be
on the outside looking in
well that was a big story with Luka
doncic as well the NBA rescinded the
technical
he got the last game and so he was able
to First Stephen chenzo gives it to
Green Green going strong offensive foul
and now green and Herb Jones coming
together
well this feels like it could turn dark
quick Brandon Ingram now
just barking at Draymond Green
[Applause]
fourth meeting of the Year between these
two teams
[Applause]
well the intensity is way up it's a huge
game for both teams and the tempers are
way up on the floor going at it with
herb Jones and I think Steve Kerr and
sitting here
that's smart coaching right there
he wants to stay out there talking but
Steve Kerr needs him he knows Draymond
Green he's going to sit